this guy over here in Germany Rudolph
diesel invented an engine that changed
everything this new engine mixed
pressure and air and fossil fuels that
all exploded and made things move this
changed a lot of Industries but the
Germans were like let's put these in
submarines and run them to charge a
bunch of batteries that we can use to
power the sub while we're underwater
it's a lot better than the hand crank
and indeed it was but there was one big
problem which is that this engine needs
air like it needs to be able to pump out
the exhaust that it makes and it needs
to be able to suck in air to like make
energy so you can't actually run your
engines underwater so these German Subs
as stealthy as they were were still very
limited because they could only standard
water for like 48 hours max before
having to come up and give away their
position so that they could get air for
their engines this is a problem that
will soon be solved but we just need a
few Wars first
[Music]